[Music]
[Music]
this week on quadriga hooligans versus
Salafists battlefield Germany last
Sunday a demonstration in the German
city of Cologne against Islamic
extremism turned into a riot about 4000
neo-nazis and members of the country's
soccer hooligan scene took part police
were attacked by rioters hurling bottles
and fireworks dozens of police officers
were wounded this was the first time
such a large number of right-wing
extremists and soccer hooligans had
banded together in Germany the scale of
the violence has shocked many but was
the Cologne bright a one-off event or is
Germany becoming a battleground for
rival extremist groups your host this
week Melinda creme hello and welcome to
a quadriga how grave is the danger of a
new right-wing extremism in Germany and
how much potential for danger comes from
homegrown terrorism here in Germany
that's what we want to talk about today
with three people who've been following
this story closely it's a pleasure to
welcome in is Paul she's the
editor-in-chief of the Berliner Daily
Tagus title former political editor at
regional newspapers in Essen and in
Lower Saxony she also held a prestigious
Nieman fellowship at Harvard from 2004
to 2005 and nice to have Alan Posner
back on the show he contributes to a
variety of media among them the debate
magazine the European he has worked as
an editor and author for the German
newspaper debate and he was also chief
of opinion for the vent um Sun tuck and
finally our our third guest is Jasmina
al Janabi she is a freelance journalist
and documentary filmmaker who works
primarily on topics involving the Arab
world she's half German half Iraqi and
is currently participating in Deutsche
Welle international exchange program
in s poll how new and how qualitatively
different is this alliance now between
rowdy soccer fans and right-wing
extremists haven't there in fact always
been contact between these groups in the
past
well hooligans Persie are not really
highly politically even so they have
some you know nationalistic and racists
and parts in their ideology but they're
more you know they like to be violent
that's their main issue it's not so much
about their political ideology so this
new this connection is new even so I
have to say to talk about the German
battlefield I think this is a little bit
too much yes indeed it was 4,500 5,000
right-wingers on the streets the biggest
amount since 1945 that has to frighten
us but on the other hand there also
would really ask everyone to look
precisely what exactly happened they're
not like over estimate and say Germany
is a big battlefield
Alan poster would you see it the same
way just a few weeks ago a so-called
meetup between these same two groups
between some soccer fans and some
right-wing extremists only drew a couple
of hundred people now as they miss ball
just told us 4500 what accounts for the
sudden escalation in those numbers and
for the politicization of these
apparently earlier unpolitical hooligans
yeah well i agree that you know it's
it's a sort of male-male thing there are
there's a lot of free-floating male
testosterone inspired violence out there
but it does make you scared when this
suddenly finds a channel against a
certain group they say they're against
salafists by which they mean basically
anyone who's muslim that's the first
thing and secondly they 4500 people beat
up 49 policemen you know so they're not
actually beating up Salafist they're
they're attacking the the government of
the country now of course this isn't you
know as everyone says berlin is in
Vienna we're not you know we're not back
to where we were 80 years ago but you
know if we always say be
of the beginnings and and stopped the
beginning so I definitely think this is
a big alarm sign when this sort of
free-floating male violence gets
channeled into a political into certain
political direction yes mean Janabi
Germany in fact has had a smaller
right-wing movement in the last few
years smaller at least than many other
European countries that were perhaps
harder hit by the economic crisis do you
think we're seeing that change now we're
seeing that change but first of all if
you would pardon me then I would go back
to your points that you mentioned before
I agree on a few points that you
mentioned but I don't agree fully on
them we have this movement mouses a few
years and they're becoming more and more
in this connection between the hooligans
and between the right extremists are not
new these connections are now since a
few years they organize themselves
already like one and a half years ago
and now they decided to take it further
and to take it on the streets and to
protest nor whatever and not all who
participated there on this movement
there in Kern are male there are a lot
of families who participated as well
there were a lot of women with children
who kind of consider themselves normal
Germans but they have other thoughts and
other ideologies and there was also a
movement from a few Kurdish parties who
participated in that movie movement as
well so there were not only German right
extremists there and only a few media
mentioned that and for example I saw a
video also on biased news where they had
some interviews with people from that
Kurdish movement to say yes regains the
Islamic state in the Levant and this is
why we're participating in this movement
without really realizing what's going on
okay Germany is not a battlefield but
it's getting harder and harder year
after year for Muslims here in Germany
especially because of the Sharia police
who started their movement there in
wahpeton a few months ago so is the new
element here there
in this poll the fact that there's a
very fertile ground for exploiting
anti-islamic sentiment in the broader
population I absolutely agree and this
has a lot to do with what we are seeing
in Syria so like it's much easier to
find people who are against Salafists
this is most definitely true but you
know what we mustn't remind us of what
Salafists are I'm not sure the term is
equally known by all of our
international viewers do you want to
give us a quick I think this is probably
you are probably the expert in doing and
definition and Salafists will go right
back to you do remind us what we're
talking about here a very fundamentalist
form of Islam very fundamentalist form
of Islam their movement is becoming
bigger and bigger for the moment as far
as I know when the so far some shoots is
not your domestic intelligence service
it's mentioning that they're about six
thousand six thousand four hundred here
moving in Germany officially members of
this movement but they're becoming more
and more and they're having a lot of
fundamental ideas and they're also ready
to take part of the fights against the
infidel in the Middle East they're also
here presenting themselves on the
streets in Germany spreading books
quran's and and trying to talk to people
to to kind of perform their idea okay I
want to come back in a moment now to
what we make of that movement itself but
now in a sport I want to make West Point
I think this is very important to have
in mind now with Facebook and all other
social media its media's it's so much
easier for these different groups to
join together for one event and the
police totally underestimated the amount
of people who would come to Cologne last
weekend and therefore it was only good
Ansari 1,500 policemen and four and a
half thousand demonstrators therefore
the violence could be so you know so
crucial and so massive because the
police couldn't damn it so but I think
we have to keep in mind that we are
Facebook we are these closed groups it's
so easy to bring 100
and thousands of people together but do
not really agree in so many things but
they have one thing in common they are
against Salafists and this is new one of
the things that fascinated me allan
poe's know when i was reading up on this
was the fact that actually neither the
soccer Rowdies nor the right-wing
extremists have had a very good image of
late and it looked like in many ways
both of them were hoping to
instrumentalize this broader
anti-islamic sentiment in the population
to sort of do some image polishing yeah
right and and and and the disturbing
thing is it said I think they're
succeeding in certain ways I mean you
know the problem is never really a
couple of thousand people on the streets
you know doing stupid things the point
is when they get taken seriously by the
center or parts of the center or parts
of the elite and we have had people for
instance from mainstream elected parties
like the so called alternative for
Germany sympathizing with this movement
and if and and you get a lot of people
sort of a dinner party sort of say well
as long as it beat up the Salafists let
them go to it you know this sort of idea
that you can use people you wouldn't
normally associate with to beat up other
people you wouldn't associate with this
has a long tradition and a very bad
tradition in German history and this is
I think what makes the whole thing
dangerous german society definitely
needs to see that you can't sort of use
hooligans nazis Rowdies whatever to beat
up Salafists or kurdish people to be you
know to do your dirty work for you you
have to defend your democracy and you
say well Society yourself you have to
defend it even so you might as well
criticize as we hopefully do the
Salafists and other extremists that I I
agree with that but you know I wouldn't
say that the alternative of Germany this
new party this really Nationalist Party
would ever agree with what the hooligans
did on the streets we have to be careful
with it I haven't talked to anybody in
the political field who really agrees
with this violence on the street against
extremists or extreme Islamists so I
think we should be you know we should be
careful not to to make it too big
because mentality I wonder how much
support there would be perhaps not
within the political world but in the
broader population as a whole how strong
is the rise in skepticism or fear of
Islamic fundamentalism within the
population as a whole well actually from
the parties
nobody really supported that movement
some from policy politics I read a few
articles about a few ministers from
North rhine-westphalia and and other
ministers here in Germany who condemn
that movement but at the same time
they're not really offering really steps
against what's going on and they're
saying oh we're having the problem under
control and this is what happened but we
will see probably will provide more
support for police we're going to come
back to the later and to the politicians
but what about the broad population
Germans just your man on the street as
we are this fear is really getting
bigger the fear is really getting bigger
after what happened in report on where
the Salafist police started to move on
and then to talk to people who are
drinking alcohol or to talk to couples
who are kissing each other I mean why do
you show that presence by wearing a
jacket written on it Sharia police so
this is like a provocation for forward
for the Germans this is the reason why
on the one hand okay this it's not good
what's happening but on the other hand
visit it was meant to be many people in
Germany first became aware of the
Salafist movement about two years ago
when salafists were distributing quran's
on the street something he has mina al
Janabi mentioned earlier and now there
is rising attention to this movement
let's take a brief look at what the
Salafists stand for
members of ultra-conservative Muslim
groups are actively seeking new recruits
in Germany the security authorities
estimate there are about 6,000 in the
country there are concerns that many of
these people could join Islamists
fighting in Syria and Iraq and there's
also the risk they will return to
Germany to carry out terrorist attacks
[Music]
meanwhile the rise of the terror group
Islamic state has fueled anti Salafist
feeling there have been clashes between
Kurdish supporter groups and Islamists
in several German cities there is fear
of a further radicalization of these
groups how should the government react
[Music]
Malin Posner how big is the threat from
Islamic fundamentalism here in Germany
the the key thing most people are
worried about of course after Canada is
homegrown terrorism is it a possibility
what's always a possibility isn't it
yeah and you can't stop it you know if
someone gets in his car like happened in
in as it happened in Canada and drives
into a you know and indeed drives a you
know hits the soldier with this car what
can you do about it
same thing by the way happened in
Jerusalem person drove an Arab terrorist
drove his car into a into a crowded bus
station killed a three-year-old baby
wasn't much on the news here because it
was a Jewish baby but anyway you know so
yes there is a danger of homegrown
terrorism but on the other hand you know
what happens is that under the general
heading of Salafism a sort of back to
the roots movement with Islam and
terrorism are put in the same box and
that's wrong you know what's wrong with
giving out the Koran on the streets
that's I mean you know the the you can
if it was Bibles you know if you and
there's always these people you know
seventh-day Adventist standing with you
know giving up Bibles and religious
tracts that's perfectly okay on the
other hand you know if someone decides
to do terrorism that's not okay that's
what we have a security force for so I
think we need to definitely give you
know put a division between people who
say we've got we you know we shouldn't
drink alcohol even the Salafist police I
mean that's really just a joke
if you have if you have you know
billboards advertising our call you can
surely have people saying don't drink or
come on and that you have to divide that
from terrorism and that's exactly what
the hooligans Rowdies and a lot of the
population actually don't do they're
generally again
any kind of Islamic propaganda in his
poll one sees widely widely varying
estimates about the number of German
citizens perhaps many of them salafists
who have gone off to Iraq and Syria to
fight and might eventually come back
here do you have any sense of what the
accurate number might be it's no one
really has a no one really knows but
it's obviously much more than one
thought a couple of years ago and it's
it's raising it's growing
might be a couple of hundreds it might
be even more but I think we have to do
is to ask why do these people join this
group you know they can drink alcohol or
not drink alcohol with the Bible or the
Quran or whatsoever I don't really care
as a Democrat but the question must be
the same with the hooligans why do
people join these groups and aren't
these people very often pretty young
people so to call losers they don't find
any other meaning in life and they give
them a meaning they make them worthy
something they feel you know I'm worth
something I'm yeah I'm important and
this is a question Germany has to deal
with and this is a real this is a really
threat to our country here's me now
Janabi what's your sense of the risk of
real true homegrown terrorism and would
you agree with Alan that there are two
very different things at work here on
the one hand people distributing
currents why not
where is there a link between the two
well for sure there is no problem with
distributing books no matter what kind
of books these are because people are
free to read and democracy what they
want to read but at the same time acting
as a police and calling yourself
Sharia police gives the total other
meaning to the thing what's going on
Pierre Fogle the German leader of the
Salafist here in Germany who was the
German who converted to Islam and there
are a lot of German leaders there as
well kind of said yeah this was a
marketing strategy to kind of waking up
the people and telling them we're here
we would like to have more people to
join our group and so on at the same
time there are a few politicians who are
mentioning that those people who are
joining those groups are losers are
Muslims probably with migrational
background but they're totally
forgetting about the
converting to disappear Fogle is not
Arab Pierre Fogle is not Turkish before
girl is German his name is already
German so like waking up and seeing what
makes those young people even the
Germans who are coming from German
background who have probably grown up in
a normal family what makes them join
such a group or what makes a young girl
with 16 17 years think of going to jihad
and getting married to someone whom she
met through Facebook going to occur
country which she never visited before
just to see what's going on this is a
main point like going to those young
people speaking with what are the their
problems okay if you're a loser you have
migrational background probably might
have a problem with language or you
might have a problem with getting a
chance to integrate yourself here in
society but what makes Germans commit to
this kind of ideology so Alan Posner how
do we stop the potentially dangerous
form of fundamentalism from spreading
how do we prevent those disaffected
young people from being radicalized and
potentially turned into violent
homegrown or foreign terrorists well I
think first of all we have to dissociate
ourselves from the idea that actually
loses I don't think so I think many of
them are quite intelligent people who
just don't get the chance in society to
fulfill their higher aspirations you
know because there's a sort of social
democratic German idea give him a nice
job give him a house giving me given
wife and kids and he'll be ok or she
with you you know but that's not the
point these are people who really want
something they're idealists in their own
twisted way I know this because I used
to be a Marxist Leninist myself and I
wasn't a loser I was someone who wanted
to change society so I think you have to
address people over their heads not just
over their sort of view them as people
whose society can somehow sedate and you
have to give them the idea that they can
actually do something in society that's
what democracy is for to somehow fulfil
their idea of their own self-worth and
that's more than just giving them a job
on what maybe you meant the same thing I
I agree with you you know but then in
your case it might be interesting to us
why you were you so
mislead you know what you wanted to do
something that's great that's a great
impulse if a young person wants to get
politically involved but why those
people you know who offer beheadings of
other people who offer to be part of a
killing team that's something different
than like you know throwing maybe stones
against some figures of capitalism or so
what makes them you know one to be part
of this absolutely brutal and crucial
regime this is more than just finding a
destiny in life isn't it there must be
some some poison in in this way they
recruit this young kid which is
obviously very hard to in to handle yes
mean are Janabi that particular issue
always makes me wonder because there's a
big discussion right now in germany and
i would like to come to it in just a
minute about whether one should stop
such young people from even traveling to
syria and iraq take away their passports
don't let them go but were they to go
and experience the poison Myton today be
somehow converted back to a more
moderate course isn't it possible that
actually seeing these terrors happening
could dissociate them from them well
first of all taking the passports want
to make it won't be a solution in my
point of view they would find another
way to go there so if you take away a
passport okay so what i'll take another
and then go illegally and this is the
first thing the second thing is that
what about those people who are really
coming back probably they might be
traumatized today they might be need
some treatment okay they integrate
themselves again here in the society
even if they're disappointed from what
they saw there in syria and iraq would
they really try to have a better life
what even if they try would they be able
to I mean if you really saw the fighting
going over there and it's not normal
fighting they're cutting off heads of
people and they're violating women
they're violating children's it's a
total completely other idea of violence
from what we have seen before in other
wars so what about those people so the
German government in my point of view
would first need to those who came back
giving them the treatment they might
need
to integrate themselves again because
otherwise they'll be like ticking bombs
you might explode in any other occasion
in Denmark is a project like that so
they really offer for attorneys for
attorneys and they really they really
work with them it's like really
post-traumatic stress syndrome therapy
they get and I think this is one way to
handle and yeah this particular group
those who are coming back and those who
are willing to talk about that I totally
agree this is really a ticking bomb
they're really talking even to the
family so they're integrating the
families in that process as well so you
can cleave out the families because what
made a girl going there or what made a
young man going there so there might be
also problem the family itself so yeah
so whole post are linking this back to
the fear of Islamic fundamentalism
clearly that fear is partly based on a
lack of confidence in the moment in the
approaches of government and of the
federal states toward keeping a lid on
the risk
what would an effective prevention
strategy look like both in terms of
keeping people from going to Iraq and
Syria or stopping them from returning as
potential human bombs and or keeping
young people on the right track at home
oh well I mean you know if that's the
you know thousand dollar question if I
knew the answer you know I'd probably be
working for the Ministry of the Interior
but you know there are some things a
shot in dollar question so well one
thing is obvious we don't as Germany we
don't have enough human intelligence
within these groups we don't have I mean
we virtually control the neo-nazi NPD
right I mean for a time we did people
working in there we don't have that many
people working within the in this sort
of in the forefront of you know of where
these Salafist who they're recruiting
and other you know not salafists i mean
they're also let's face it turkish
extremists and so on also recruiting
people from within the turkey the
Kurdish community and so on and so on so
we don't know enough we only notice it
when the people go and suddenly the
parents ring up where's my daughter
where's my son so we have to do a lot
more there we have to realize that as
president
have said Islam belongs to Germany
therefore they also belong sort of to
the circle of you know they we have to
recruit people from that community we're
going to go in there and help the German
States that's the first thing the second
thing is I really think we need to make
people give Young Turks young Arabs
young Iranians a real shot at doing
things in the in in in the community and
becoming people and not as they are
still today second-class citizens in
many cases and you know that's that will
that stop people going off to be
terrorists or committing terrorist act
no because we know this from our own
history violence has an incredible
attraction look at the way that people
went to the first world war singing this
is just a hundred years ago look at the
attraction of the Nazi sa hordes for
academics students they were the people
who burnt the books yet this is not
going to go away this is something you
have to deal with all the time it's the
Salafists today it's the hooligans
tomorrow the day after tomorrow is gonna
be something different but you know
that's more a philosophical question in
a spool the state the federal state
where these hooligan demonstrations
occurred last weekend has said it now
was watts to strengthen prevention
efforts but if you look at empirical
studies about the effectiveness of
attempts at prevention you have to
conclude conclude the results are often
quite mixed why is that well it's I
think the the very point is we have to
take them serious and we have to take
the problem series and we have to get
closer to these groups I totally agree
we have to watch them and we have to
understand why they are willing you know
to demonstrate against whomsoever so the
problem just on the other other hand is
to try to handle that by sharpening the
laws by taking away passports this is on
the surface the state then shows yes
we're taking action they might feel
stronger but does it really by the very
end of the day help I don't know I think
only a very little bit we have to come
close to these people and take the earth
their problem series end we have to
offer them perspect
in this country's also the hooligans who
are 25 years old all the wives of the
hooligans very many of them are jobless
yes there might be some intelligence
people there but there are there might
be even intelligence if they're losers
that's what I wanted to say earlier on
but they are really outlaws in that case
that they don't have very good jobs
they're very often jobless they just do
not have the feeling they're part of
this community and you know they're
worth something this is again the main
point
yes Mina Janabi Alan Posner told us a
moment ago we seem to know a lot more
about the right-wing groups than we do
about Islamic fundamentalist groups but
in fact for quite a while
the state clearly didn't know enough
about right-wing groups I'm referring of
course to the murders that were
committed with impunity over 10 years
murders against members of the immigrant
community migrant people with migrant
background here in Germany by a
right-wing group called the NSU
state turned a blind eye did not do
enough to investigate it and people here
in Germany often say that many
authorities seem to be blind on the
bright eye in terms of right-wing
violence would you say that is still
true it is still true I mean even the
burning of that papers which belong to
the case that okay so not burning but to
like myself I lost so how can in a
German in the German is in Germany you
are not like talking about any stay to
there without law without democracy such
important papers get lost on the same
time is there more concentrating on the
violence committed by Muslims or sella
fists or other organizations rather than
violence committed by the right-wing
what they're doing I mean as you said
before it's nothing new there even like
professors in some cities in Germany who
don't seem typical German coming from
India from Africa or get attacked by
young men who belong to that right wing
yourself experienced xenophobia
anti-metal Eastern I know you're not
yourself a Muslim but have you had
direct experience yourself give
your name and it's not that I've
luckily never been attacked on the
street but I keep on hearing comments or
sometimes I had the experience a few
years ago during a job interview where
they told me seriously in my face that
they only invited me to see how good my
German was and to see what kind of
performance I would do because they
never had the experience with a
journalist having like a bilingual
background so this is the reason why
they wanted to meet me but they would
never give me the job Alan Posner do you
agree with Yasmine al Janabi that there
still is a systemic systematic tendency
to underestimate danger from the right
yes point taken and I was I was wrong
actually to say we know what's going on
the question is actually was there a
collusion I'm it's even worse than not
knowing
was there a collusion between certain
state authorities and people in our in
the NSU or in the NPD or other
right-wing fascist Nazi groups and that
is something that is really really
horrible just just to reminder for our
viewers NSU of course was that group of
people who committed the murder as I
spoke up and NPD is the National Party
of the riot they have contacts to our
internal secret services we have one in
each of the federal states plus one
federal and in and there were there were
there was there seems to have been
collusion and that that is really
horrible for anyone who wants who's
interested in democracy so we were
actually too close there and I agree has
it changed well I think they're doing
things you know I think I think that's
meet the NSU has been a wake-up call I
think at least at the top of the
security forces that people have been
sacked and so on I think it's gonna
change but I agree totally that anyone
who has a non-white skin or has a the
wrong kind of name that will experience
stuff like as many as said on a daily
basis and and it is even small things
like I I am I myself someone writes me a
mail and I write back liebe someone so
dear somes with with a calling
by a male name because I don't know that
in the Iranian or Turkish or whatever
actually it's a she that name so you
know it's small things it's small things
but we we say I mean we like to say
we've accepted that Islam and and
immigrants belong to Germany but you
know I'm in the small things even people
like us you know can hurt people I think
it has changed the awareness is growing
bigger also in politics and the fact
that there are more young politicians
who the migrant background are joining
the parties you know Steinmeier
all foreign minister has one of his
really close co-workers she's a Muslim
so this helps a lot if they have people
you know working with them and
politician themselves the awareness is
getting bigger there's still a lot to do
sure no question but I have the feeling
and I'm watching that very closely and
very critical as running a my paper who
has a leftist tradition so but I really
would say in this in this point we can
say there the awareness is growing it's
still a lot a lot of things to do it's
not that I want to see everything is
fine because we don't have so much more
time left and I'd like to turn to the
question of what then the authorities
both at the political level and
administrative level in the federal
states need to be doing about this
alliance between right-wing extremists
and rowdy football fans going forward
because they're telling us they do plan
to demonstrate again possibly here in
Berlin yes mina al Janabi should those
demonstrations be banned are these
simply people out looking for a fight
who should not be permitted to take
advantage of the public streets to do so
it's a very difficult question to answer
because on the one hand if you say no
you're not allowed to to do your protest
so they would say okay so the German
government is really invaded by the
Islamists so we really have to do with
any something about the government but
what I think is just let them go on the
street do whatever they want to do is I
want to beat themselves up between each
other let them but then the police has
to be ready
doesn't the situation has not to be
underestimated they have to be ready
when those people go on the street maybe
the violence and third
hundred policemen under the street of
Cologne that's quite a number really so
impaired they were unprepared I mean 50
policemen got beaten up it's not like a
small number 50 policemen and they were
not ready they were expecting 500 and in
the end they showed us what that puzzles
me very very much Alan poster because in
fact 7,000 people had registered and the
authorities knew that well don't ask me
I wasn't there I mean I wasn't
responsible I don't understand it
especially it's a I mean it's a
red-green it's a left-wing government in
in North rhine-westphalia which should
be more you know have its antenna up
more when that kind of thing happens
this was this was it was disgraced they
need more resources
well obviously the police need more
resources I mean okay yes yes just you
know they weren't aware of it they don't
follow like the the new media they did
they didn't and we had some interviews
with policemen they did not have any
clue that they were like all this you
know closed groups on Facebook where
people met and there were leftist
organizations who warned them and said
listen people this is gonna be bigger
than you think but they just ignored it
so they are very poorly educated when it
comes to to the Internet and to new ways
of communication sure they do they need
more resources in the sense of more
armored vehicles and more guns more
whatever or do they need more
intelligence more awareness really this
is the first thing you know and they
need to be better educated and to have a
better awareness what might happen with
these new coalition's you know which
really can be built up so easily now
within a couple of hours actually and
then they say okay we're going to
demonstrate in Hamburg and this is only
one and a half or two hours away from
Berlin so you know when they see our
okay the police is getting ready ready
in Hamburg to fight us so they move
immediately to Berlin they're so fast
now so mobile so this is a big
demonstration so on the 15th of November
plan for handbook I actually disagree
with you I think demonstrations here
when you know they're gonna be violence
they should forbid people forbidden yeah
it's a it's a big especially in this
country it's so important that we have
the freedom of speech and the right to
demonstrate but when you know when
you know that there will be thousands of
people who will be violent and they know
that their problem made that then I
think that it's that it's a right for
them it's actually the duty of the
states to forbid demonstrations like
that especially on a day like the 9th of
November when Berlin will be packed with
hundreds of thousands of tourists Alan
Posner would you agree with that
certainly there's an anglo-saxon view
that says the clash of different points
of view is the best way to discredit a
bad one yeah I would say forbidding
things isn't going to help even on the
9th of November even in Berlin you know
I mean you know this for for years and
years and years and Berlin we had
demonstrations on the 1st of May which
always turned violent but you know the
the the these the Berlin Senate didn't
forbid these demonstrations that it
happen let citizens mobilize against it
and now the 1st of May is the great
celebration of peaceful celebration in
court spec so I'm not saying it's gonna
happen with the hooligans is different I
just wonder you know I think you have to
explain what the background of the first
well yeah I mean the point is at the
time when the first mate it was always a
riot I know in our paper everyone was
saying forbid it forbid it forbid it no
you have to combat it and put political
means one of the means by the way is
more policemen and women and more police
men and women from Muslim backgrounds
for instance all that kind of thing has
to be done we are cutting we're slashing
the budget of the police and then we
expect these people to go out hold their
heads you know I mean out and get bashed
up by but you know beaten up by
hooligans or whatever
I agree in that point but do you really
think if you would have more Muslim
women on the police side that this would
help to keep the hooligans away from
really doing harm to people on the
streets do you really think you can
control that then you would need to send
in the army to can control like ten or
fifteen thousand of hooligans who are
expected Janabi the german constitution
is a very interesting document because
it enshrines two very very important
principles but sometimes they're in
conflict with one another as they appear
to be here
one is the inviolability of human
dignity that of course was an outgrowth
of the Holocaust of the
Second World War saying this must not be
touched and that is perhaps the key
clause of the German constitution but
free speech freedom of opinion that is
also very very high in the list how do
they get balanced here this is the
problem this is so what why I said let
them protest let them go on the street
just be ready for them because we live
in a democracy you have to hear their
opinion and the other opinion doesn't
necessarily mean that you have to be in
one opinion since you're living in one
country but let every party get their
chance to talk to express themselves to
speak out but find a point where you can
also communicate with each other not
violence is never going to be the
solution preventing people from going to
the street is never going to be the
solution
taking the passports isn't going to
prevent people from going to Syria to
Iraq to fight also wherever so justify
the solution talking to those young
people to see what they really need to
see what the problem because it seems
like the German government totally
forgot about young people Alain Posner
both in s poll and Yasmin al Janabi told
us at the outset of the program that in
a way Germany is importing the tensions
of the Middle East and of course we're
seeing that happening everywhere now the
whole phenomenon of homegrown terrorism
is essentially just that are we then
looking at potentially quite a long term
problem here because we're told that the
conflicts in Syria and Iraq could go in
for years it definitely will this is you
know this is this is a well there's lots
of things happening I can't analyze the
Middle East you know in one sentence but
take simply the war between Sunni and
Shiites and this is a war which has been
going on for centuries and it's going to
has now turned violent in certain parts
of the world and it's not going to go
away and it's gonna you know it's gonna
create terrorists it's going to create
stuff like the Islamic state and that's
going to be imported to us we have to
learn to deal with it it's not going to
you know it's not gonna it's not a
danger to German democracy it's a danger
to german certain german people are
going to be victims of attacks and they
have to be protected that's why we need
the police force to be strong and
security operators to be strong that's
not a right-wing concern answer
left-wing concern it's protecting
citizens but we have also be very
careful not to get hysterical do you
think Eunice Paul certainly in the past
there have been tendencies on the part
of many Germans to think well we just
need to stay out of things and then
we're going to be fine one heard that
quite a bit after the 11th of September
2001 the sense that this is sort of you
know this is the kind of thing that
happens to the US because it goes out
enactus world policeman but we're not
going to do that and therefore do you
think that sense is changing to Germans
feel more vulnerable and is that part of
what we're seeing here absolutely it is
changing for many reasons because of we
are really getting more vulnerable and
something will happen sooner or later in
Germany in Europe in London in other
countries I think this is clear we can't
be mainly because many people might some
of these jihadists have no German
passports how can you prevent them to
coming back to their home country and
then the other thing is which is really
changing in this country is the
discourse do we have to get involved or
not when you listen carefully to our
defence minister to our president they
are really like me rowing I think the
changing of the discourse in the German
society people do understand that we
being so strong so rich the richest
European as a country we have to take
part in the defence of our democracy and
the defence of the military way of our
democracy so there's a shift thank you
very much thanks to all of you for being
with us today and I look forward very
much to continuing the discussion in the
future given that it most likely is a
challenge that's going to be with us for
a while thanks to all of you for being
with us today stay tuned and see you
soon
[Music]